mine hunter besides being a compelling
story is one of the most immaculately
produced TV shows out there while david
fincher doesn't direct every episode he
imbues the show with his perfectionistic
style of filmmaking so it's no surprise
that we can find many great examples of
excellent editing throughout the show I
want to break down the editing of
several scenes from season 1 & 2 to
illustrate some of the subtle but
effective techniques minehunters editors
are using to tell the story thank you -
movie for making this video possible
there's no major spoilers in this video
but I'm going to build on some of the
ideas I talked about in my breakdown of
Bohemian Rhapsody zwarst scene so
watching that video first might give you
a better foundation for some of the
concepts I discuss in this video one of
the things I criticize Bohemian Rhapsody
for is the speed of the edit and some
places mine hunter cuts just as quickly
as Bohemian Rhapsody does but in mine
hunter these faster cuts work they're
never jarring and they never pull you
out of the scene one of the reasons for
this is how mine hunters editors match
the rhythm of the Edit to the dramatic
movement of the conversations uncuff him
please in this scene where FBI agents
bill and Holden interview Charles Manson
editor Taylor Nelson varies the speed of
the cuts to match the rhythm of the
conversation I'm showing you at the
bottom where the edits are in the
timeline watch how fast er bursts of
cuts are used as conflict surges broken
up by longer shots that give us a moment
to catch up you and then you say your
children are killing know I'm seeing
you're a killer killed no I
I did not direct anyone to do anything I
didn't know what they wanted to do
notice how there's a pattern to the
length of the longer shots and the
length of the bursts of faster cuts the
rise in conflict in this part of the
scene isn't linear
each longer shot punctuates a moment
where the conflict plateaus and the
faster cuts punctuated moments where the
conflict flares you didn't stop the
meeting I always let children go if he
falls that is how we learn comes from
before you're not supposed to let
children fall you're supposed to guide
guide them into what gather them into
what you got of them into you [ __ ] so
[Laughter]
there's anger that you feel the nature
did this did the anger did you got for
you
each of these three longer shots are
slightly shorter so there's a sense that
tension is mounting and the final shot
is the longest as Manson gains the upper
hand here's another example of using
rhythm as a dramatic tool in this scene
agent Craig Smith and dr. Carr are
interviewing Wayne Williams when he gets
upset and yells you call me names jr.
mr. Henning don't call me Elmer Wayne or
Elmer or Wayne don't call me that ever
if you look at the timeline you can see
how quick the shot is where he yells and
how that stands in contrast to the
length of the shots around it the
technique here is actually to break from
the established rhythm of the edit with
this cut breaking the rhythm is jarring
for the viewer and the speed of the cut
helps emphasize how quickly he snapped
quickly cutting back to Gregg has the
added benefit of letting us see his
whole reaction if we look at the
beginning of the shot you can see the
editor has actually cut back to Gregg
before he's even had a chance to react
the editor also uses sound cues to
determine the length of this cut
cutting to wane as he yells hey and away
from him as his elbow pounds on the
table these sound cues make the fast cut
feel more seamless call me there's
another technique used in this moment
but it doesn't have to do with rhythm
maybe you caught it when the editor cuts
to dr. Carr's reaction they use a shot
that crosses the line of action the
direction Wayne is speaking from on the
screen flips which I think helps
reinforce how quickly the conversation
has taken a turn this technique is
actually used several times in this
scene to highlight key turning points in
the conversation in this moment dr. Carr
is struggling with deciding if she wants
to say this I was in a relationship once
that I think is very similar to the one
that you were in with Dean notice how
she literally spends from one side of
the screen when he daddy Duty goes like
you want to take guys out there daddy
cuz the one who were treating just like
that he did that about right see I could
be a shrink to the other Wayne is the
one speaking the whole time but the edit
helps place emphasis on car and what
she's thinking by moving her position in
the frame this also shifts the line of
action from Wayne a car to car and Greg
as car considers whether she should say
what she's thinking of saying with Greg
present we can see this subtextual
conflict in Anna Taurus performance but
the editor is helping reinforce that by
directing the audience's attention to
where the actual conflict lies in that
moment a conflict that as of that second
only exists in the mind of the character
it's a great example of how an edit can
be used to communicate inner psychology
a few moments later this composition
across the line is used again my lover
foolish she is her status to control and
subjugate me I never saw it that way
until I was no longer with her you're
lying I'm not I know what that kind of
confusion feels like when you're caught
between someone you admire and a whole
lot of bad decisions before when this
angle was used it was because a Wayne
had grabbed the upper hand and the scene
shifting the conversation using
aggression names jr. mr. Hannon
don't call me Elma Wayne or Elmer or
Wayne this time cars the one who has
grabbed the upper hand shifting the
conversation by saying something that
resonates with Wayne when you're caught
between someone you admire and a whole
lotta bad decisions crossing the line is
also used in the Manson scene the two
primary lines of action in the scene are
from holding two Manson and from bill to
Manson
for most of the scene the camera stays
inside these two lines in this moment
when bill calls BS on Manson and Manson
switches from making excuses to
threatening bill the camera pops outside
of that triangle across the line of
action if I wanted I could kill you with
your mic cord with your pants off
when Manson backs down on his threat but
I want to love myself so I'm not going
to the camera returns Manson across the
line believes bill on the outside
showing he isn't backing down mine
hunter can get away with breaking the
180 degree rule in these moments because
the geography of these scenes is fairly
simple they're not action scenes but
also because they're using the jarring
effect of crossing the line of action to
communicate something about the scene
whether it's rising conflict or a shift
in the conversation
while creating compositions is the job
of the cinematographer and the director
it's up to the editor to choose which
compositions are going to be used at
which moments in the scene the choice of
which composition to use can communicate
a lot we can see an example of
composition being used as a narrative
tool in this scene we examined earlier
this entire scene is 10 minutes long and
it has its own narrative structure one
element of that structure is this
two-minute subsequence where there's a
small dramatic arc during the two
minutes at the beginning of the two
minutes the interview is faltering did
you see who's your father figure was it
your daddy doctor car starts thinking
about whether or not she wants to reveal
personal information she does everyone
reacts and then the interview begins
going smoothly what was he like quiet
the editor uses this specific profile
composition to mark the beginning and
the end of this arc small details like
this book ending of a moment of conflict
help the audience feel the narrative
structure of the scene in the opening
interview with Manson the editor slowly
moves in on Manson and the agents by
selecting progressively closer
compositions
[Music]
the scene starts out with a slow dolly
push in towards Manson and the agents
but the editor continues the momentum of
this push in the Edit even after the
camera stops moving the progression is
clear if I show you just the shots of
Manson the camera and the scene are
slowly pushing towards this moment bill
says Manson is and Manson is largest in
the frame as Holden vows to the king the
use of editing like this helps the
moment feel to the audience like it
feels to the agents in the scene while
Manson is small in stature he slowly
becomes larger than life just like a
dolly push can be used in cinematography
to emphasize something a series of shots
that slowly move closer to the subject
can be used in the same way of everyone
the agents interview Manson has the most
mythos surrounding him and this emphasis
helps reinforce that sometimes the power
of a composition rests in how often it's
used whatever life is it is right and
wrong that nothing to do with it so the
murder of seven people just is what it
is in it no one ever dies no one never
lives throughout most of this scene bill
and Holden are out of sync Holden is
enamored with Manson and bill is
becoming angered by him but there's a
key moment where they're both on the
same page for that moment the editor
reserves this shot both of their
reactions together the composition of
the shock communicates a lot on its own
they're equal in the frame presenting a
unified front but this is the only time
we see this shot in the whole scene even
though they likely shot most of the
scene from this angle this shot helps
indicate to us that Bill and Holden are
on the same page because it's reserved
for a moment when they are if it was
used throughout the scene willy nilly it
would have less impact in this
the Civic moment it's awful raging
eating feeling us inside me in this
scene from season one at Kemper becomes
lost pursuing a specific train of
thought I could feel it consuming my
insights as fantastic passion when
Holden says something fantastic passion
that shifts Ed's attention and the
conversation it's good phrase no there
was the editor uses a shift in the
composition to mark this shift in Ed's
attention after showing Holden's line
fantastic passion instead of cutting
back to this shot of Edie the editor
chooses to cut to a slightly different
composition the conversation has shifted
and so has the composition of the scene
one of the reasons mine hunter can get
away with faster cutting like this
without disorienting the viewer is that
the editors are often paying close
attention to the eye lines within a
scene often in mine hunter the
characters reactions looks and glances
at one another are what motivate what
the cut will be and when the cut will be
placed watch this section and see if you
can guess who the editor will cut to
next pay close attention to where the
character on-screen is looking there's
nothing that is in love really nothing
how much more they do you want to listen
you need to walk on a different Street
guy put your clothes on backwards let
everyone laugh if you're a coward
charlie a coward who takes no
responsibility for his actions yeah you
eat meat with your deed each cut feels
seamless because almost every time we're
cutting to where the character on camera
is looking and often when we land on
that cut the character on screen is
looking at the character that we just
cut from and when they shift their
eyeline
it helps cue the next cut like any
technique this doesn't have to be
followed religiously there are lots of
times the editor breaks the eye line to
cut to someone else but when they do
they motivate the cut in other ways the
pace of the shifts in eyeline also helps
set the rhythm of the Edit there's a
pace in the performance of how long it
takes for the actor to look from here
about your mother my mother
to here and the editors use that pacing
to inform the timing of the edits so how
did that become sort
it was Sadie who started here in
messages and the White Album the final
editing technique I want to highlight is
one that is used frequently in mine
hunter to help transition between scenes
pre lapping audio is when you bring in
the audio for the next scene before you
cut to the scene visually
here's an example there's no real
heartfelt emotion
blunt former star about to brief the
Commission broken we can hear tench
talking in the next scene before we see
him for this to work the editor has to
find a moment where the characters in
the first scene have naturally paused or
stopped talking this is one of those
editing techniques that seems a bit
strange but it works somehow within the
language of film you pulled the plug you
can't do that
the city's been asking for our help
Commissioner Brown even said so maybe
the city didn't like they're gonna help
you in fact if I edit a post lap
continuing the audio from the previous
scene into the next one it feels
extremely jarring and strange just to
wake me up when you come back to bed
there's uh von Greenwood the Skid Row
slasher compare that to the actual
pre-op transition just still wake me up
when you come back to bed
Bristol's only an hour so away so we
don't have to do road school to get to
it there's uh von Greenwood the Skid Row
slasher but there are ways you can make
a post slap work and mine hunter does
that too
in this scene the dialogue from the
previous scene continues in the next
scene as diegetic sound coming from the
tape recorder he who confesses obtains
mercy I was lost until I some of these
editing decisions may seem obvious to
you but remember there are hundreds of
ways the editor could choose to
construct any one moment the work of a
good editor is often to find the
combination that feels like the most
obvious natural flow of the scene
alternatively it might seem like I'm
reading too much into the meaning of a
specific choice or edit but often the
editor is choosing intuitively what they
think feels right for the scene they
might be thinking I'll cross the line
here and this will mean this but they
might just be doing it because it feels
right either way it doesn't matter the
Edit is communicating that meaning
whether the editor is consciously making
those decisions or just intuitively
constructing a flow for the scene that
feels right whether the editor is
consciously or intuitively making these
decisions part of how we can find good
editing is by looking for meaning in the
Edit in many cases when you scrutinize
the edit the less arbitrary the editing
decision seemed the
the Edit thanks to movie for sponsoring
this video
Looby is an online streaming cinema
service every day you'll get access to a
new movie and you'll get 30 days to
watch it right now you can watch startup
on movie which is a gritty raw prison
drama that has one of my favourite ben
mendelsohn performances in it which is
saying a lot
movie has an excellent selection of
international art house and indie films
i don't have access to an indie art
house theater where I live and movie
goes a long way towards helping fill
that void for me by choosing programming
that I wouldn't get access to otherwise
and you can use movie all around the
globe you can go to movie comm / Thomas
flight to sign up for your extended free
trial that's mu bi comm / Thomas flight
to sign up for your extended free trial
today with Disney Plus HBO max Apple TV
plus and more coming the world of
streaming TV is getting more and more
complicated to help you navigate that
world and find the content you enjoy
watching fellow youtuber Jackson from
skip intro and I have started a podcast
called stream theory and if you're
interested in streaming TV you should
check it out thanks for watching and
special thank you to my patreon
supporters
[Music]